nous sommes en direct avec un morad el
hattab écrivain et géopoliticien bonjour
et merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors pas vraiment d'annonce à l'issue
de cette conférence de presse on l'a
entendu le chef de la diplomatie russe
qui explique qu'il faut continuer les
négociations des négociations via les
terrains bilatérales pardon mais aussi
des négociations à poursuivre avec le
groupe de minsk
quel rôle joue à moscou dans ce conflit
dans la résolution de ce conflit ce
qu'on peut dire que c'est finalement la
russie qui prend le lead sur les
négociations a mené par le groupe de
minsk qui on le rappelle regroupe la
russie la france et les états unis
votre question est la question
essentielle
en réalité c'est là aussi qu'il a mené
l'essentiel des négociations pour une
raison très simple très simple il faut
voir l'idée globale de ce conflit
parce qu'en réalité ce conflit est
composé d'une double intention il faut
vraiment voir l'arrière fond sur le plan
géopolitique
tout ça est fait pour épuiser la russie
est imité sur l' influence dans la
région
en démolissant d'une part les
coopération de la russie avec l'europe
de l'ouest
nord stream 2 en l'occurrence dans la
baltique et d'autre part en interdisant
son soutien à la guerre de sibérie parce
que à travers cet autre guillemets
guerre artificielle l'on finira par
savoir qui est derrière il ya une
tentative de briser le cordon ombilical
de la gare de série car la chaîne
d'approvisionnement passe par une base
russe en arménie
ça c'est l'arrière fond et c'est la
question cruciale après vous l'avez
rappelé dans votre partage
remarquablement bien d'ailleurs que la
turquie a inoculé sur place c'est ce qui
pose problème pour l'instant des
jihadistes dont ceux gars se sert depuis
la guerre de syrie depuis 2011
alors vous voyez très bien que pour les
russes c'est une question essentielle et
vitale vital que ça se règle au plus
vite
on joue la turquie dans ce conflit
puisque c'est évidemment landais de l'un
des protagonistes de la situation de ce
qui se passe en ce moment dans le
haut-karabagh quelles sont les
intentions d'ankara
la vraie question on a vraiment le
sentiment que la turquie pour le coup
sert des intentions mondialistes de
destruction des nations
c'est quand même assez incroyable
j'ai plusieurs parce qu'on va faire un
petit rappel c'est quand même la russie
et l'iran le dire publiquement qu'ils
ont permis à erdogan de se maintenir au
pouvoir après le coup d'état manqué
contre lui donc il à grandir ils m'ont
dit celui ce kilo vif faible mais
n'oubliez pas que la russie ne va pas se
laisser faire dans cette histoire parce
qu'il ya un effet de ciseaux pour
épuiser la russie parce que d'un côté
vous avez vu que la crise below russe
après laffaire navale 8
maintenant ce ce conflit artificiel pour
permettre à train de sanctions qui est
d'ailleurs piloté par l'allemagne et la
france afin d'empêcher le projet
énergétique stratégique nord stream dans
la baltique et je vais vous dire une
chose si sanction il ya par rapport à ce
qui se passe actuellement tout ça
précède les guerres ou suivent les
guerres donc la turquie joue un jeu
extrêmement dangereux elle ne sera pas
suivi sur le long terme par d'autres
puissances 1h l'iran l'iran a fait le
choix de l'arménie sachez le
une menace existentielle pour la région
on viens de l'entendre dans la bouche de
notre correspondant antoine claireaux
trois décennies de médiation le rappel
pour tenter d'apaiser la situation dans
le haut-karabagh d échec jusque là sur
quel
fondements reposent aujourd'hui l'espoir
de voir la situation s'améliorer dans le
haut-karabagh c'est très simple je pense
je fais la prédiction que d'ici très peu
de temps vont se réunir à moscou le
président azerbaïdjanais le président
arménien pour régler une bonne fois pour
toutes le conflit parce que aussi non
des méthodes seront employés qui seront
des comédiens oui disons le moscou a
tout intérêt à éliminer
excusez moi l'expression les mercenaires
syrien qui agissent en ce moment dans le
cadre de ce conflit
après ça tout le monde reviendra à la
table des négociations pour l'instant le
problème et inoculation de ces
djihadistes par la turquie dans cette
zone puisque n'oubliez pas qu'ils sont
des mercenaires sont des gens qui
combattent sans drapeau sans cause
donc pourquoi elles sont là je vous le
dis je le répète pour une double
interface est l'invité d'épuiser la
russie et de limiter son influence
une russe ne se laisseront pas faire